[Music]
hey you guys what's going on
everybody just got here and already you
guys are talking about sex toys it's
that kind of day i guess
send me a picture oh i finally got one
and it was just some big old black thing
it was it was a bottle there's a bottle
of some energy drinking something that
says something
i said like something about galaxy to
the stars [ __ ] something and i don't
know what it was so i just said so you
got your butt plug
and he started [ __ ] with me and then
talking about flashlights and [ __ ] i
said yeah i wore that [ __ ] out man word
out testosterone friction got to that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] didn't last a day
well now i'm kind of wondering if there
is some kind of drink out there that
comes in a bottle that's like a butt
plug so it's like dual purpose you'd buy
it
well no i'm just
i was just watching once since you
brought it up i got an energy drink to
talk about actually this one's black too
this one is that going up your butt no
no it's not it's gonna go up yours
sure this one it's called intense it's
intense it's good it slides up in there
electric citrus you plug it in
i don't know what it is
this is uh
this is uh like in the energy drinks
from uh
dollar general or the dg as we call it
yeah
this is something this is a dollar
general this is some redneck [ __ ] that's
next to our house it's not next to our
house but it's like right next to the
neighborhood it's like within walking
distance
you look it tastes like a sweet tart
but like they all taste like sweet tarts
this one's like a week sweet
[ __ ] they all taste like sweet
tarts it's only a dollar though
it's kind of weak flavor
i mean it doesn't taste like a sweet
tart they all kind of taste like that so
you might as well just get the cheap one
because none of them are any good
[Laughter]
it doesn't taste like a sweet tart no it
tastes like what those sweeties another
big long roll
for you that you've got a long roll yeah
the ones that you when you're a little
kid yeah i know you're a little bitty
one yeah you got from halloween that's
what it tastes like
it's weak not really good either very
weak not really good either i mean this
should taste like a sweet tart like one
of the [ __ ] dick oh
that's what it should taste like but it
doesn't it tastes like little sweeties
you're like no no i'm i'm not a big fan
i'm not a big fan of energy drinks i
gotta say
uh yeah so we're talking about a killer
crocodile movie uh in case you didn't
know slasher fred says this movie is
kind of like jaws but with alligators
yeah you can tell that jaws was like a
big uh influence on this
uh this movie was called rogue and it
came out in 2007 and i just noticed
while i was just flipping through this
was a total random pick uh we were just
flipping through like the free movies on
youtube it's free on to be as well and i
was like oh i think i kind of heard that
this one was okay and it's like what the
hell i'm kind of in the mood for a
killer crocodile movie because i do kind
of feel like
there are a lot of killer crocodile
movies but
it's not as many of those as there are
killer shark movies you know what i'm
saying the shark movies are i mean the
sharks
well i don't well in japan not ouija
shark yeah
luigi shark was was not watchable but it
it made me laugh on a couple occasions
that's true yeah it was a funny show
it was a funny concept all the [ __ ]
sharknado and the three-headed sharks
and i thought they were [ __ ] great
shark to push shark swords [ __ ]
because they you know they're [ __ ]
with you well yeah
is there a shark a croc or crocker shark
i'm sure there's gotta be gotta be
there's gotta be they've done every like
conceivable monster mashup and they
haven't even it's not just like two
animals together sometimes they'll do an
animal and a natural disaster like
lavalanchula yeah well that's what they
are which that's a real movie they're
they're disastrous films yeah
it's a natural disaster so it's it's not
that crazy now so i had heard that rogue
was uh was pretty decent like as uh
killer croc movies go interestingly 2007
saw three
killer crocodile movies two of which
including this one were australian there
was another one called black water
uh that was also australian and then
there was another one that was called
prime evil
um i haven't seen either one of those
and it seems that the jury is out some
people seem to like rogue better some
people seem to like uh black water
better um so i can't really judge
because i haven't seen black water but
as far as killer croc movies go this was
actually a pretty good one because you
said
when we first started watching it you
thought it was going to be like goofy
like a sci-fi original kind of movie and
it's not it's like a pretty serious
um you can tell like it's pretty low
budget
um
they're taking it seriously but that
said uh the crocodile looks pretty good
there's like some shots later on in the
movie where they show it more where you
can obviously tell it's cg
but some of the close-up shots actually
look really good because they did
actually use like a big animatronic or a
big puppet and it's really well done
like in the close-up shots i think it
was a good choice too much like jaws
to not show the crocodile as much
i will say that i think they left it a
little bit too long
but
because it's not that long of a movie
but i'm not gonna [ __ ] on it for that
because i think they did a good job like
building up suspense and stuff this was
directed by greg mclean who was the same
guy that did wolf creek
and
i don't even think we've reviewed wolf
creek have we we probably should because
that's like a really good uh movie
that's more like a that's a serial
killer movie
also set in australia and the same guy
that played mick taylor
in wolf creek was in this too but he
wasn't like the main role but he was
like playing kind of
he was playing a smaller role and he was
like a lot different
than the guy that he played in wolf
creek
interestingly this had
uh what's her name uh rada mitchell in
it
and
i it's it's weird because we see these
movies all the time and i was just kind
of like god damn it it's like she's so
familiar i was like what the [ __ ] have i
seen her in i've seen her in like so
many things but i couldn't like think of
what it was immediately
i probably recognized her from
pitch black she was in pitch black she
was in silent hill
uh which i've seen a couple of times she
was in the remake of the crazies so i
might recognize her from that
and then kind of the main guy is
michael
vartan
and again i was like where the [ __ ] have
i seen that [ __ ] he was in one
hour photo that's where i recognized him
from
and sam worthington is in this although
this was before he was in avatar
so he's not like the main character and
spoiler alert he gets killed like much
sooner than i expected him to because i
guess i was like seeing it this from
today's standpoint when he's like a
bigger like a more famous person but
when this came out he wasn't that famous
so he was in terminator salvation he was
in the clash of the titans remake he was
in a bunch of other [ __ ] but i think
avatar was like the thing that kind of
kicked it off and i can't even remember
what year that was what year was avatar
2009. he doesn't know what spark i don't
even know heaven knows i don't remember
the movie i sucked i couldn't i didn't
like it i it's like i liked it okay but
i didn't really um i didn't see it in
the theater somebody like loaned it to
me and i was like that was that right i
didn't get what all the hype was about
it was just it was fine it was fine
[ __ ] blue people
[ __ ] blue people yeah i saw that [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] theater and i was like
this
[ __ ] sucks blue people big tree okay
[Laughter]
they were going out of the way trying to
make me care about them you know what i
mean i saw the way it was coming there
was like okay the humans are the bad
guys the blue people are the good guys
and [ __ ] yeah or whatever their tree
got knocked over and just
i i i saw that i saw what they were
doing
well i think the avatar like i said it
was a fine uh you know it was fine
[ __ ] i think yeah i think it was like a
victim of uh somebody you know uh no
need for me to said it was a bit over
hyped yeah i do kind of feel like it was
a victim of its own hype yeah because
everybody thought oh my god this is the
best [ __ ] thing ever but then like a
couple years later i was like wait
avatar who you know what i mean it was
kind of like that which is one of the
which is one of the weirdest things ever
i think that was one of the biggest
movies that a couple of years later
everyone just like totally forgot about
yeah what's funny about that one is that
all they do is oprah hype it they were
like guilt tripping you oh you have to
like this movie if you don't like this
movie you're a bad person at all just
that was the attitude that they had with
that [ __ ] but then another movie came
came out
that was in some ways like it but a lot
better
called elite a battle angel and if you
liked that one you they called you an
[ __ ] and then you want to make a damn
then you want to make a [ __ ] sequel
to it [ __ ] those [ __ ]
and and i thought elita battle angel was
great
yeah i know that was great yeah
uh
let me see oh slasher friend so there's
also the movie crawl yeah and that was
like the sit now sam raimi didn't direct
that he just produced it yeah i remember
we saw that in the theater that was that
was pretty good too i will say
sharks are scary
uh crocodiles might be scarier i don't
know it's kind of i guess it depends on
the movie because crocodiles in
alligators to a lesser extent
can get you eat whether you're in the
water or whether you're on the land
whereas like sharks not so much you kind
of have to go in the ocean and then they
can eat you whereas crocodiles are like
we don't care [ __ ] if man if
crocodiles could fly we'd all be [ __ ]
because then they could get you then
they could get you land sea and air
but uh yeah so uh so the setup of this
is this is a very very straightforward
killer croc creature feature type movie
like i said it's
you know it's taken seriously it's not
goofy in any way like like i said the
crocodile can't fly or doesn't have
three heads or nothing like that it's
just a big ass
crocodile i think it's supposed to be 25
feet something like that it's a big ass
crocodile now they did actually base it
on a real
big-ass crocodile in australia named
sweetheart
um although i don't think that one ate
anybody that they know of
um but yeah so basically the setup of
this there's just like a group of people
australians americans like a whole gang
the main guy who's the guy from one hour
photo michael vartan uh he
is like a travel writer i guess and he
has come to this like sort of backwoods
touristy place in the australian outback
to do this like crocodile tour and he's
like the main character there's a bunch
of other ones too so they're all on this
tour boat
and uh
the
rana mitchell she plays uh kate and
she's like the tour
guide
and so they're out on the tour it's like
you know there's 20 30 minutes of like
gorgeous landscape porn
uh and you kind of get like a little
hints of uh crocodile stuff
and then there's they're gonna go back
and then there's a
there's like a flare so someone's in
distress and they have to go over there
and see what's going on like maybe a
boat broke down they get over there and
the boat is
under the water and like turned over and
they can't see anybody and then the
crocodile busts their boat like that and
like drives them up on this
little island and it's like a little
tidal tidal island so that as the tide
comes in the island's gonna be
underwater so they have to figure out
how to get the [ __ ] off this little
island without swimming through the
water because they're gonna get eaten by
crocodiles
or that one particular crocodile
now interestingly
there is a normal version
of this and there's an unrated version
now i think that the version that we
watched which was we watched the version
that's on 2b like i said it's also free
on youtube
um like with ads
i think that's the normal version but
from what i could determine the unrated
version doesn't have any extra gore in
it
this isn't a real gory movie
um a lot of the attacks on the people
like happened sort of off screen
which didn't really bother me all that
much some of the kills uh you know were
kind of you know you got to see the
person like get chopped up and i will
say if you are sensitive about i'm this
i was mad about this
there's a delightful dog in this
named kevin
kevin doesn't make it yeah okay and uh
i was i was upset i think you were like
in the other room but i was just kind of
like eat all the people i could just
leave kevin a load gun and then i was
like god damn it
he ate kevin and it was like it was it
was bad because they actually like they
don't show it but then they kind of show
like the aftermath and i was just like
[ __ ] you moby god damn it why are they
always gonna do that you could have just
eaten more people instead of the little
dog
the the the movie was kind of taking
itself seriously it wasn't goofy like i
thought it was gonna be which is
kind of a good thing and a bad thing
there's a trade-off when you do that
when it's serious
you now have to take it a little more
seriously and it
it has to be it has to have a certain
kind of tone and certain things have to
happen for me to me to enjoy it when
you're talking about alligators or
crocodiles and i kind of thought the
movie was a little bit bland it it was
they had a good cast the acting was good
you know the way they shot it and
everything the location was great
there's just something kind of bland
about it yeah i get what you're saying
you know like there's
kind of save me it felt the same as a
lot of other ones i will give it that so
i was just kind of
i didn't want to ex kind of started to
check out of the movie mentally i was
like uh okay
it was it went right a little bit yeah
i mean it's not down to zero so maybe
what is that damn oh okay it's coming
back okay i don't know i heard something
here
what
oh that's um that that speaker over
there is old and it makes like a weird
static noise staticky noise every now
and then like when the yeah it went red
it went red
which is weird i haven't okay wait it's
coming back it's coming back it's coming
back come on
you can do it you can do it that's some
weird [ __ ] it's just i mean it just
depends it was fine yesterday that's a
weird [ __ ] it was fine
cut out and then it comes back and then
it cuts back out
well yeah i mean i didn't think today's
show was gonna be all that long because
like i said
um you know this movie was fine if you
like like killer crocodile movies this
is a good one like a serious one if you
want to see like a goofball one then
uh no i'm down to zero again if you want
to see a goofball one then this one
isn't that because this is a totally
serious like realistic
uh killer crocodile movie i did like the
um
the kind of final confrontation like
inside the cave
um you know i thought that was kind of
cool where he was right man [ __ ]
god damn it i don't know what the hell
is going on with this
we're losing the connection this is so
[ __ ] there it is there it goes we
don't know why the connection's going in
and out people yeah it's like yesterday
when the day before it was certainly
happening it was totally fine and then
today it's just one of those acting ass
it's acting ass yeah it's acting it